oh and the Oakland A's move to Las Vegas
since the legislature released its bill
for financing a new 30 thousand state
seat Stadium all right news now
investigator Kyle Payne has confirmed
that the legislature should be able to
get that bill approved before their
session in Carson City ends on June 5th
Kyle joins us in studio now with more
Sasha tonight we can confirm some of the
numbers we've been waiting for after
weeks of asking about the financing of
building that new stadium and who
exactly is paying what we have to go
through the whole bill and make sure we
understand uh the creation of a tax
District that we're going to be doing uh
enhancements from the state uh you know
how long this is going to how long the
bond is going to be issued for I mean we
just have a multitude of questions I
think we're just all going through the
bill line by line line by line state
senator Scott Hammond confirmed the
financing details in the bill outlining
the A's stadium deal of the 380 million
dollars of Public Funding the state
would contribute 180 million with half
of that being repaid with tax revenue
generated by the ballpark Clark County
would fund 145 million dollars of that
amount much of that from bonds they'd
pay down over time the County
Commissioners did not return our
repeated request for comment instead
telling eight news now quote the county
is not in a position to provide anyone
on camera for an interview at this time
understanding that while the bill
language has been introduced the bill
has not yet been heard and the A's also
had no common saying in part quote we're
going to respect the legislative process
and not comment until after the hearing
meanwhile on the field the A's owned by
billionaire John Fisher have the worst
record in baseball and are on their way
to one of the worst seasons ever with
the lowest attendance in the league
making it seem unlikely that they'll
fill this new expensive ballpark which
we saw spectacular renderings of earlier
this week Major League Baseball is
asking more of uh John Fisher I think
that they're asking more of the A's uh
they're asking uh that that they put out
a really good product out there and so I
think that that's going to happen once
we see that that move a couple of other
notes about the bill after reading it
one lawmakers are setting aside money to
provide services to help the homeless in
and around the strip and second that in
building the stadium at least 15 percent
of the stadium project needs to involve
small local businesses
now that Bill should end up before the
Senate finance committee Monday and on
to the Senate the state senate floor
rather right after that